moi je sais pas dans un rapport de force
vis-à-vis de l'éducation nationale et
cercles ce que je pose dans le livre
c'est pas le fait de me sentir dépossédé
par une institution du simple fait que
il s'agit d'une institution
moi ce qui me gêne au sein de cette
institution l'école c'est que c'est
qu'elle l'ait inégalitaire et que petit
à petit elle tend à réduire le champ des
possibles de mes enfants de nos enfants
moi c'est ce qui me viennent en réalité
dans dans l'école donc voilà je cherche
pas à récupérer mes enfants et de la
mainmise comme ça de l'institution au
contraire moi j'invite tous les parents
toutes les mères à prendre une place
plus grande au sein de l'institution au
sein de l'école et il s'agit pour moi au
contraire de d'investir ce cet espace là
et pour y imposer un rapport de force en
vue d'un système plus énigmes plus
égalitaire plus juste qui respecte
davantage la dignité de nos enfants donc
il s'agit bien pour moi de deux de ses
valeurs de défendre des valeurs
d'égalité de justice de respect la
dignité humaine pour moi c'est ça la
question centrale en réalité si je veux
m'impliquer politiquement pour mes
enfants c'est pour qu'ils puissent
grandir ambitions ambitieux curieux
respectant leur dignité qu'ils puissent
réussir
qu'ils soient pas orienté petit à petit
vers un sou marché du travail entre avec
un travail qui va leur casser le dos qui
va casser leur santé mentale
c'est bien ça l'objectif voilà c'est pas
pour faire la bataille en soit avec avec
l'institution
[Musique]